first question towards the back Kawai
Paulin tunas ESPN Brasil congratulations
I'm just wondering when you first got
traded to Toronto what went through your
mind was that one of your preferred
destinations and how did your feelings
evolve or change during this run and how
do you feel now I mean we all know where
my destinations were but obviously you
know like I said when I was there on my
opening day meeting that uh you know I
was focused on now and you know I wanted
to make history here and that's all I
did I'll just you know I'm still playing
basketball no matter what Jersey I have
on the the guys here been you know
making Rennes in the playoffs before I
came so I know they were talented team
and you know I just came in with the
right mindset let's go out and win
ballgames at exile probably a day later
or the day that I got traded and told
him let's go out and do some special no
little your best friend left I know
you're mad but uh you know let's make
this thing work out and we were here
today mark here in the third row Kauai
mark Schwartz ESPN wondering what went
through your mind when Steph Curry had
that look and whether you thought that
the game could be in their hands at that
moment and also your thoughts on when
klay Thompson went down with that injury
well first I'll start with clay you know
I hope he's okay
you know I never want to see you
a good friend of mine go out like that
I hope he's able to you know recover
from in our you know nothing serious
and I'll just you know when he went down
I was I just really thought about him I
didn't care about the game that much and
you know I you know once he left you
just we got to flip our mindset back to
like trying to beat the lawyers so
that's what I did and with the shut shot
with Steph it didn't look like it was a
good shot I mean he hits those shots but
I wasn't I wasn't too worried about it
at that moment obviously he can make
that he made it millions of times but I
was I just was focused on the rebound
you know I been in situations like that
in the finals that I lost up two or
three points and we lost that game
because of rebounds you know I forgot
who shot the ball you mean you guys know
the story it was the last two
possessions for Miami they got two
chances to shoot threes well four
chances at the basket out of to
possession two possessions and that was
my focus I was trying to get the rebound
and once he missed the ball I tried to
keep tipping it so some more time go
right now didn't want to grab it right
away so they could foul me and draymond
in the Witte would point nine seconds
and called a timeout and came over from
there
quite reap reap foregrip with CBSsports
straight ahead i you've been through
this roller coaster of a couple years
and I was sitting with the final strophe
the MVP trophy next to you again and I'm
curious how these couple years have
changed you as a man and changed the way
you look at faith and kind of your
priorities in life
well just a year last year you know a
lot of people were doubted me you know
thought I was either faking an injury or
didn't want to play for a team and I was
disappointing to me that how that was
out in the media because I love the game
of basketball like I always say if we're
not playing his games is and for hurt I
mean you're down so me just you know
going through that and you know I just
knew that I'll have to make myself happy
and no one else and I have to trust
myself and whatever what it doesn't
matter what anybody has to say about me
I Know Who I am as a person I know how I
feel and always just trust herself and
that was my goal my focus saying you
know that's why did it one of the things
that you know I take on the floor I
don't care about what media has to say
about me or what if they want me to
score whatever thirty points because I
did the game before I'm gonna come out
and play the right way I'm not trying to
make headlines and you know that's just
things that you know I pretty much
learned just throughout this journey of
being in the NBA and so I mean I saw it
just keep growing up as a man and unless
why say I just think about my past life
and try to learn from situations and be
and be wise and learn from others last
two questions standing on the left side
collide damn lucky with the Los Angeles
Times along those lines you sense me
today you've said I just want to play
basketball I'm curious what it was like
emotionally to hear that final horn to
know that a year after you had
basketballs were taken away from you
that you were able to to be on stage
with an MVP trophy to be in a locker
room what did that mean to you it means
a lot like I said last summer was it was
tough I was still rehabbing
you know just trusted the process really
with myself and told myself I'll be be
back I wasn't all coming back at 2:00 I
could be the player I am today I wanted
to come back there in the same shape and
form without you know coming out playing
fire games and every injuring something
I wanted to be able to play the season
you know what I did this year I wasn't
able to play 82 but you know I'm happy
that I got to the 60 games but uh you
know just just be able to win a
championship these years there's
something special for me because you
know how the last year everybody was
looking at me and I stayed true to
myself and I had a great support system
and once I got here to Toronto
they understood everything and the mole
kept moving from there last question in
the back
March NZ Johnson the undefeated you're
obviously known as someone known for
their defense how special was it to
receive the MVP award from Bill Russell
I was very special
obviously I didn't come out in this
series Shona Winnie you know it was a
whole group collectively tonight Fred
played amazing in that for Karl played
amazing tonight throughout the whole
game pascale play big and you know I
just kept driving and you know pushing
and you know I ended up with the trophy
but everybody deserves it
thank you quite